uh why don't we go next to ben from los
angeles ben you're on the air
hello david hello first time caller how
are you i'm doing well
um that's awesome um
but a question about uh by then putting
in so i've got to ask you to either or
both turn off your discord notifications
and don't use push to talk because every
10 seconds we're hearing a discord bling
and the i get 20 emails every time it
happens so please please please um uh
see if you can do that where do you do
that by the way i'm sorry
where would you do that so if you go
into settings under notifications turn
them all off and then under audio video
settings turn off push to talk
beautiful please proceed governor
okay so biden just sent in 3 000 troops
in into
poland and around the
ukraine
area
um i'm just wondering if you think
that's going to escalate any further
uh at this at this point it's anyone's
guess
um indeed the united states is sending 3
000 troops to eastern europe in the
forthcoming days uh poland and romania
there were already 8 500 us troops on
alert um at the end of uh january i
don't think um
any prediction i mean listen
anyone can predict this will escalate or
this will not escalate i don't think we
know because i think it fundamentally
comes down to what putin is actually
planning and i don't pretend to know
what putin is actually planning
okay thank you for that what do you
think
i do have one one last different
question so
um pfizer last week said that they are
testing an omicron
uh variant of the vaccine yes uh
i'm wondering
is as we progress into
2022 and 2023
will
what it means to be fully vaccinated
change based on that so i know some
colleges and
um
some
small states and some events do require
you to get boosted
i'm wondering if
over time we will
the
basically the premise of being fully
vaccinated will require like four shots
i think um much like with other things
it'll just it'll be are you up to date
on your shots it'll be it'll be less
about the number of doses it'll just be
are you up to date so you know as as
covid
continues to evolve it would make sense
that for example two years from now
the vaccine that would be considered up
to date is going to be different than
the one based on the live virus that's
the vaccine that's been around now for
more than a year
so um you know i think it'll just as as
we get beyond the pandemic phase into
the endemic phase
and vaccines like the flu shot will be
modified it's sort of like if i say yes
i got the flu shot five years ago you
would say well you're not up to date
because that was for the strains then we
have a we have an up-to-date flu shot i
think it'll just change to that rather
than a number of doses
you think how like there's people who
don't get flu shots like every year do
you think i'm i'm sure the same is going
to happen with the
covid absolutely vaccines no doubt um
do you think like states
and um different
places will care about
how up-to-date you are as we as we move
into the endemic phase uh that will
depend on whether it becomes
significantly less severe or not and i
think different states will have a
different perspective but if it
continues to be severe
then there will be states that will
continue to insist on vaccine
requirements if it really does become
milder and becomes like the flu or more
mild then i think it will be handled
like the flu vaccine which will be uh
much less strict but i think we just
we're just not going to know for a while
let's see yeah
okay thank you so much david all right
thank you there's ben from los angeles
that's gonna do it for today i'm so glad
i was able to speak to so many of you we
will take calls again and we'll take a
quick break and be right back